so what is behind this deadly spate of
attacks according to local news reporter
Jerry Cena it's a question on everyone's
mind there was a lot of rumors in
regards to the attacks why did it happen
and in two weeks time it happened twice
one such rumor concerns the identity of
the killer shark the ferocity of the
attack and the severity of the injuries
incurred seem to point toward the oceans
most fearsome predator people was saying
that it was a white shark great whites
are the largest predatory fish on the
planet growing up to 20 feet in length
they are powerful hunters
able to propel their bodies completely
out of the water when attacking prey
from below and they are responsible for
more fatal attacks on humans than any
other shark so is this the species
behind the spike determining the type of
shark may help locals prevent attacks
from happening again
shark expert dr. Enrico Gennari studies
great whites off the coast of South
Africa he believes the answer to whether
a white shark could be responsible for
the Seychelles attacks may come down to
where these predators go and why why
sharks travel alone thank all their life
is about moving Gennari has spent the
past 13 years tagging these predators to
track their movements using a long pole
he attaches a small non-invasive device
to their fins
okay shot coming
[Music]
three-two-one
it's on yes
now we tuck it
[Music]
through such tagging studies experts
like Gennari have discovered that white
sharks are highly migratory in fact some
great whites will swim up to 1,000 miles
each month or more than forty miles per
day to reach a destination often white
sharks are attracted to a specific place
because of food but in their quest for
prey white sharks don't just go anywhere
it really depends on net temperature in
the water
unlike most other sharks great whites
are warm-blooded
that means they always maintain their
body temperature above that of the
surrounding sea so they thrive in a
particular climate where sharks usually
like water temperature quite cold
this is the key to the investigation in
the Seychelles because great whites are
typically found within temperature
ranges of 54 to 75 degrees Fahrenheit
but the water off of the islands
routinely reaches into the 80s
why should definitely don't like
tropical water like in session so that
shark in this session most likely was
not a great white shark the culprits
identity and the reason it attacked
remains unknown for locals and tourists
in the Seychelles
it's a disconcerting premise it's still
a mystery and people still wanted to
know why
[Music]